If I have seasonal allergies, is that a symptom of gut problems?
Since now, it seems like everything is gut, gut, gut.
Regardless, during symptoms, is it better to try to tough it out?
Or is it less stressful on your immune system just to take it into history?
So seasonal allergies is typically not a gut problem,
but it can be a barrier problem.
So seasonal allergies can be a buccosal barrier issue with the nasal buccosal barrier
and respiratory buccosal barrier.
So it can still be a barrier problem, it's just a gut barrier problem.
So you can still take some things that will help build those barriers.
But you certainly can have antibodies to different things that you've developed,
antibodies to different things that you're breathing in, like, polyd and things like that.
So is it bad to, should I tough it it out, or should I take it into history?
No, I'd say take it into history.
So there's natural into history, things like we have clear history,
scavenger and products like that that, of course, it's to the other things that are
actually good for cancer patients as well.
But a medicine over the counter anti-histamine can actually be good for a cancer patient.
So there's studies that I have them on the member site and I think I have them in the cancer course
that I've had them in my book about the benefits over the counter into histamines.
The studies were on breast cancer, but it could be attributed to just about 80 cancer.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it over the counter anti-histamine.